yeah
thank you very much at my direction the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention is issuing guidance for
communities of faith I want to thank dr.
Redfield and the CDC for their work on
this matter and all the other work
they've been doing over the past what
now seems like a long period of time
today I'm identifying houses of worship
churches synagogues and mosques as
essential places that provide essential
services some governors have deemed to
liquor stores and abortion clinics as
essential but have left our churches and
other houses of worship it's now right
so I'm correcting this injustice and
calling houses of worship essential
I call upon governor's to allow our
churches and places of worship to open
right now if there's any question
they're gonna have to call me but
they're not going to be successful in
that call these are places that hold our
society together and keep our people
United the people are demanding to go to
church and synagogue go to their mosque
many millions of Americans embrace
worship as an essential part of life The
ministers pastors rabbis Imams and other
faith leaders will make sure that their
congregations are safe as they gather
and pray I know them well they love
their congregations they love their
people they don't want anything bad to
happen to them or to anybody else the
governors need to do the right thing and
allow these very important essential
places of faith to open right now for
this weekend if they don't do it I will
override the governor's in America we
need more prayer not less thank you very
much thank
it's a pleasure to join you today that
was a great announcement from President
Trump I'd like to introduce dr. Burks
right now she has a wonderful
presentation pursuant to reopening
America and some great data to share
with you so I'll let her kick this off
Thank You Kaylee if we can have the
first slide please I wanted to start out
with a summary of the number of
Americans we have lost to date but the
exciting thing for all of us is the
decreasing mortality over time and I
think it both is a real aspect of the
amazing health care workers on the front
line the ability of people to share at
the front line how best to care for the
patients and the continuous decrease in
mortality over time next slide the other
thing that has decreased this is
significantly over the last month as new
hospitalizations we can see now that
there's over a 50 percent decline in new
hospitalizations although every region
of the country is different we were
encouraged to see these new
hospitalizations declining next slide
I've talked before about the extensive
surveillance that CDC has made available
to this country this is looking at their
syndromic surveillance from emergency
rooms you can see that both kovat like
illnesses shown in the orange and shown
in the blue influenza like illness
taking up both of those cases together
you can see significant declines week
over week a number of people coming to
the emergency room with these illnesses
that goes along with our new
hospitalizations what we like to do is
triangulate data put data together from
multiple sources to see if we're seeing
the same trends so that we can ensure
that we're making progress together next
slide this is their influenza like
illness surveillance system that has
been up and running for more than a
decade now you can see each of the
influenza peaks of this last year I
think that's very important
people love because we had influenza A
influenza B and then we had cope it like
illness and while we know it's kovat
that's the last orange peak what we
really find encouraging is across the
country we are below baseline why is
that particularly important now these
are reported state by state county by
county
so each cap
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
even Hollywood get Japanese yeah I love
you honey halfway en ella loop la hora
que tal como la salon ER CR absalom
arrived at the world
Eno Caracas important evolution
[Music]
[Music]
I'll say menorah Mahabharat noburo but I